[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the 2018 season that's gone it's over
with did you win a championship
congratulations nobody cares anymore but
we're on our way to another one you lost
last year just wipe the slate clean hit
yourself with the men in black pen
because right now your preparation
starts for 29 teams championship and oh
by the way side note and Tony Brown I
got you come to Oakland come to Las
Vegas coming here early five figures
that'll get this done this is your
fantasy fire drill
we are not in some studio in New York
we're not cramped in somewhere look who
we are we're at the sports book here in
Las Vegas and I am at camp for your
fantasy fire drill the right atmosphere
to be in and we're gonna be here for you
all season long obviously your today
3:00 Eastern news Pacific next Thursday
as well and then every Sunday morning
we're gonna get you ready but we're
getting you ready for the season right
now with fantasy football rankings
sleepers bust and most importantly we're
helping you out drop your questions drop
your comments in there I'll be getting
to them throughout the show and I'll be
getting to them after the show as well
here's my first question from Mikey
who's the best rookie running back I go
to Oakland we just talked about Antonio
Brown for Josh Jacobs my number 19
running back in my latest rankings love
him he's gonna get all the touches there
don't worry about Doug Martin it's Josh
Jacobs but don't forget about David
Montgomery and Myles Sanders J sacks 10
team PPR League drafting in the nine
spot to keep go with Michael Thomas or
lay beyond Bell well I don't really love
lay beyond Bell with the Jets this year
but I love Michael Thomas and speaking
of ten teams let's take a look at my
draft board it's the first round it's my
top ten picks this is what I'm doing
look at this my names and lights mom I
did it we're in Las Vegas my name's in
lights it's not Wayne Newton lights or
Elvis but I'll take it
hey number 10 is juju Smith Schuester
the man in Pittsburgh and by the way he
is now the man in Pittsburgh no more
Antonio Brown there he's a hot topic
isn't he right now the targets almost
exactly the same share last season for
juju Smith Schuster and Antonio Brown so
Browns are gone let Vance McDonald and
James Washington and Donte Moncrief let
them fight over those targets this is
the man now this is where Ben
Roethlisberger is going when he needs to
bail himself out when he needs to go
deep third year wide receiver juju Smith
Schuster has worked his way into that
wide receiver one conversation in fact
I'm so high on juju I think he could
finish this season as the number one
overall wide receiver in 2019 he is a
first-round pick and to be a good start
to your draft he's number 10 on my list
but let's go back to my top ten and we
go to number nine
and that is Michael Thomas and Michael
Thomas why do I love Michael Thomas well
he's the hundred million dollar man he
has over 300 receptions in his first
three seasons and was paid accordingly
by the New Orleans Saints I'd argue
maybe the safest player and all a
fantasy football is that man right there
there's no real number two wide receiver
for the New Orleans Saints they've added
Jared Cook we'll get to Alvin Kamara
spoiler he's in the top five but this
guy can dominate I mean his Twitter
handle is can't guard mic and that's not
a lie that's exactly what the case is
nobody can stop this guy he's got a Hall
of Fame quarterback throwing him the
ball and he's on top of the depth chart
for the New Orleans Saints as safe as it
gets at wide receiver Mike Thomas is my
number 9 player on my first-round draft
board now we move into number eight
number eight is Julio Jones it's weird
to call him this but by comparison he's
the elder statesman of this group and
what was the argument last year he
doesn't score touchdowns I had someone
who was in my wedding someone who I
consider a friend see my rankings for
this year and go he doesn't score
touchdowns well update your narrative
this guy does score touchdowns he's
dominant yeah they have Calvin Ridley
yeah they have Devonta Freeman coming
back I like Austin Hooper but if I'm
down 30 points going into Monday Night
Football
you know who's sweating not me my
opponent is because they see that guy
they see this face that man is locked in
and then they go oh no am I gonna hold
off someone who's got Julio in my lineup
no I'm worried about that guy and that's
why you want him on your team he's gonna
score he fills up the stat sheet and he
is still demand for the Atlanta Falcons
I don't care what his ages you're still
drafting Julio Jones with a bunch of
confidence now we move back into my top
ten but wait you know before we do that
let's take a moment let's let's take a
matte moment because I know where you're
at right now we're working our way to
seven to six you go
you know two months ago this was a
Melvin Gordon spot Melvin Gordon wants a
new contract Melvin Gordon is not with
the Chargers right now and I feel that
pain I like Melvin Gordon as well but
the Chargers are not showing him that
love the love that we have for Melvin
Gordon and because of that you can't
take him in the first round I don't want
to take him in the second round in the
third round
okay let's hope that Melvin Gordon only
misses a game or two and it could be my
second running back that moves up in the
world after a couple weeks but right now
I feel for you Melvin Gordon and I feel
for all of you who want Melvin Gordon on
your fantasy team because in the first
round Melvin Gordon just won't be there
that has been in that moment now back to
the top ten we'll bring it back up
another receiver on the board number
seven on the list is Davante Adams and
an indica I'd ever have to say this
about the Green Bay Packers
but Davante Adams has proven he could be
quarterback proof two years ago Aaron
Rodgers was hurt Davante Adams dominated
last year Aaron Rodgers played through a
knee injury all season long Davante
Adams dominated and I like Geronimo
Allison I like MBS nobody's close to
this guy nobody not Jimmy Graham night
Jay Stern Berger this is the man in
Green Bay and I think Aaron Rodgers
bounces back I don't love Matt Lafleur I
don't know why anybody would but Mike
McCarthy's gone he's coaching Pop Warner
football which is what he looks like he
should be doing anyway so Davante Adams
who in some formats was the number one
wide receiver in all fantasy football is
about as rock-solid of a pick as you can
have and if you want to call me a number
one wide receiver be my guess you will
not get an argument from me but that
does bring us back to my top ten and it
does bring us back to number six
who is my top receiver and we go to
Euston for DeAndre Hopkins nobody
dominated the targets for his team last
year like DeAndre Hopkins about 33% of
the target share a massive number by
comparison brown and Jew during the 28
percent range key Kikuchi missed I'm
already hurt this season
well fuller missed I'm more of a deep
threat yeah they had a Duke Johnson
that'll help a little but this is the
man for the Houston Texas
no doubt he's the man for the Houston
Texans and a lot of formats he was
number one he's still number one for me
receptions yards touchdowns
deshaun Watson throw them to the ball
throwing the ball you don't worry about
this guy ever and if you want to take
him over any of the running backs that
you may end up seeing here in the top
five I don't have a problem with that
either maybe the best receiver in all of
football is my number one receiver in
fantasy football now we a they read
challenge flag I didn't think they had
those or coaches or anything here here's
the good part though we don't have to
call New York I'm gonna handle this one
myself
so here's the challenge and I know what
the challenge is I'm here and I'm seeing
it you've seen my rankings we just
revealed those where's James Connor
he was so good last year he stepped in
for Libya about where's Le'Veon Bell
he's with the Jets yet a year off he had
his feet up he's feeling good where's
Joe Mixon hey Jake greens not there mix
he's gonna get all the touches I
acknowledge all of that I do say this
about the first round if I don't love a
player there's players I just like a lot
more without red flags or concerns I'm
gonna take them but if you say Matt
those receivers are great some of the
will be there in the second round Tyreke
he'll be there in the second round
Odell Beckham he'll be there in the
second round you are correct and if you
feel confident enough picking late in
the first round and you could take one
of those running backs and come back
around and take a Beckham or a hill or
Michael Thomas then go ahead and do so
so challenge accepted I understand it's
the compromise if you want to go
one-on-one feel free to do so I hear you
in the comments I acknowledge your
comments but I'm taking the receivers
instead back to the board we go and
there's no more receivers there's a
spoiler for you because number five is
david johnson now don't turn this off I
know I know what happened last season
I'm aware that David Johnson let you
down don't blame David Johnson don't
hate the player hate the game hate the
coaching staff that no longer exists in
Arizona and love Kliff Kingsbury because
he's gonna fix this man what happened
last year
let's run him into the wall let's run
him into the line oh let's run you don't
run David Johnson into an offensive line
that's the worst in football right up
the middle over and over again and
expect something to change he's really
good but get
Mountains face Kliff Kingsbury is gonna
stroll this guy the ball he's gonna lead
the team in carries he's gonna lead the
team in targets they have an interesting
receiving core but nobody's more
established than that man right there
David Johnson so look put last year
behind you we'll get to that coming up
in a little bit and Trust David Johnson
and Kliff Kingsbury offense I don't care
if the Carnales win six games because
that man is gonna win you a bunch of
fantasy games this season back to our
top five now and it's another running
back here at number four in Alvin Kamara
the New Orleans Saints last season were
the number six rushing offense in
football Alvin Kamara played a big part
of that we think of Alvin Kamara as the
man catching all the passes in this
backfield but I'll tell you this when
they didn't have Mark Ingram this guy's
carry shot up and I like latavius Murray
he's a sleeper this year but Alvin
Kamara is still the man in this
backfield and Alvin Kamara is going to
catch passes and be PPR platinum if
you're in those point perception leagues
you know what you might even say he's
the number one guy and I will give you a
strong argument against that my only
concern is that the other names we're
gonna see here and the next three picks
are gonna get more carries he's the most
reliant on catching the ball it's not a
bad thing he's in a great offense he can
score double-digit touchdowns there's
nothing wrong with Alvin Kamara arguably
a fantasy cheat code for this season but
now we go to the top three and the top
three will include a player that I have
a hell of a lot more confidence in
putting at number three after what we
found out literally 20 minutes ago
according to Edward ur who was embedded
in Dallas has been there as whole
professional life he's saying that the
Cowboys gave zekiel Elliott and offer
that would make him a top two running
back in the NFL he's gonna get paid that
way I think that's what he wants he took
his time in Cabo he cleared his head
like what we're doing here in Las Vegas
we're trying to clear our heads for some
people that hasn't worked out so well
what Zeke is ready and truthfully I like
that we haven't seen him this preseason
because he's not taking hits he's not
taking unnecessary reps
we'll have him out there for a week one
so if you're drafting
tonight tomorrow this weekend I think
the confidence is right back in Zeke to
be out there in week number one as the
focal point of the Cowboys offense I
think he's the best pure running back in
football he's more important than dak
which is why he's gonna get paid first
he's more important than Amari Cooper
which is why he's gonna get paid first
and they could lead the league in
rushing and touches this season have
that confidence in Ezekiel Elliott to
carry your team once again but that's
number three we have two spots to go and
we go back to the top ten but before
that it's time for a matte moment yes we
have multiple matte moments here in the
first round and we're talking about the
top of the draft but is that truly the
best place to be maybe you were at my
mock draft article just a few days ago I
selected from the 10 spot potentially a
perfect 10 spot I started with Michael
Thomas I came back around with juju
Smith Schuster I love how that team
looks maybe you're thinking doesn't that
make more sense and yes it does because
if you pick at 10 or 11 or 12 you're
gonna get two players in the top 15 or
16 but if you pick at number one which
we'll get to in a second what are you
coming back around with T Y he'll love
them Andrew Luck's leg is busted Antonio
Brown helmet frozen feet Derek Carr
Keenan Allen love him he's already hurt
so the confidence I want to have is
picking at the back end of the first
round not the top of the first round
because I like the players I'm gonna get
from two spots look at that in context
two players that you feel great about
instead of just one that's another matte
moment but now we get to the top two we
get to number two and year three for
Christian McCaffrey now I don't know if
you saw his Instagram post or all the
stories cuz the NFL is totally over
covered
he's eating fish or not eating fish he's
posting his workouts he's on key though
it works but you don't care that I'm
saying that that he's eating you know
natural sugar which I also am eating but
I don't look like that I mean I'd love
to look like that but if I did I
wouldn't be doing this for a living
Christian McCaffrey has been known for
his past catching skills but I think
we're gonna see a lot more of Christian
McCaffrey running the football and the
thing I love everybody asked about
handcuffs who's the guy it's gonna still
touch this who's gonna back him up the
Carolina Panthers don't have that guy
right now so you're not worried about
someone stealing touches you're not
gonna be sick of this when some random
guy in the backfield scores a touchdown
and steals from Christian McCaffrey
because it's not gonna happen because
they don't have that player and
Christian McCaffrey down the stretch
last year when Todd Gurley got hurt he
was number one and if you want to make
him number one this year I don't have a
problem with that
Cam Newton could do one thing that I
feel confident in each and every week he
can get this guy of the football and
it's gonna happen again this season
Christian McCaffrey is another player
who's gonna take you to a fantasy
championship but he's not number one
number one is the man in New York or at
least Rutherford I'm from Jersey I know
what it is the Giants play in Jersey and
say Kwan Bartley heads into year number
two as the number one player in fantasy
football I'm not the only one saying
this this is not some hot take there's
no doubt safe one Bartley is the number
one player in fantasy football and you
might think the Giants stink that's okay
if you had say Kwan Barkley next year
last year you know where I'm going with
this if they're getting beat by two
touchdowns they're gonna throw this guy
the football sterling Shepherds got a
bum thumb Golden Tate suspended four
games
I like Evan Engram most importantly this
guy is Eli Manning proof or daniel Jones
proof it's not hard to just dump the
ball to this guy and in terms of
all-around talent is gonna catch it he's
a great runner if you're stuck and
you're down big he could bust off an 80
yard touchdown so I'm not worried that
the Giants think because he's great
and he is my number one player say Quan
Barkley the guy whose quads are bigger
than my entire body that's who you want
on your fantasy team this year
take him with confidence and don't worry
that the Giants think I know they stink
but say Kwan Barkley he doesn't think at
all there's my top ten you have
questions we get to those questions
right now hit about hit him up in the
app by the way I'll be there after the
show's over we're gonna get to as many
as I can
mike says when is it okay to draft Todd
Gurley oh what a bummer of a situation
this is doesn't play in the Super Bowl
very little they draft Darryl Henderson
they bring Malcolm Brown back is he have
arthritic knees whatever he's the third
round pick to me there's been nothing
positive about
early and coaches and tape players that
are related to them they're all full of
it they're not gonna give you the right
answer they're not gonna give you a
clear answer they're gonna lie that's
what happens in the NFL third-round pick
for Todd Gurley law says who's the
handcuff to Todd Gurley is it Malcolm
Brown or Darrell Henderson I lean
towards Henderson he's a more explosive
player
I think Brown is kind of the failsafe
don't be making an effort to get
Henderson in the sixth round it's too
strong Colin says 2019 Devin Funchess
pulse check same guy from Carolina or up
that up for that Ebron role in the red
zone I think he's the guy who eats into
E bronze touchdowns this year
I loved functions as a sleeper I only
kind of like functions as a sleeper at
least until we find out more about
Andrew Luck's leg injury
Karen says who can I draft in round
three don't make me look like a fantasy
football genius how about carry on
Johnson of the Detroit Lions I love
carry on Johnson Matt Patricia defensive
coach wants to run the football looks
like it right
big beard penciled is here backwards hat
defensive guy defensive guy wants to run
the football here's the other part about
carry on Johnson it's gonna catch it the
old Hicks Denver now he can win you a
championship this year
WS 47:12 man PPR snake
I had the 12th pick should I go to
running backs two receivers one run you
don't have to plan this far ahead and
that actually is going to lead us into
my draft rules strategy how do you
approach a draft let's look at my rules
number one oh related to that right
there the best draft strategy is a fluid
one like you got to be flew in the show
my eye if he falls out we just throw it
behind me that's okay I got the show
we're covered if you go into your draft
and say I'm gonna take a running back in
first round I'm gonna take a wide
receiver in the second round I'm gonna
take a tight end in the third round I'm
gonna take a quarterback in the fourth
round if you can plan that far ahead and
know who's gonna be there
stop playing fantasy football and go
play the lottery cuz you're gonna win if
you can see the future you don't know
that that's gonna happen I did a draft
my mock draft I took two tight ends in
the first six rounds why I didn't expect
wonder Henry to be there I was able to
put him on my team if you lock yourself
in you reach on positions you reach up
running back for a running back who's
really not that good so you play the
board if you think wide receivers look
like the best players available then you
go take them number two don't draft a
quarter
back early and I know what you're
thinking well I don't know if you're
thinking this but you may have drafted
this player last year that's Patrick
mahomes I think that's someone's back up
for interpretation
it's a champ stamp because he won people
championships last year you don't have
to go do this and you don't have to take
him in the second round of the third
round by the way if I get you a
championship this year you have to get a
camp stamp and that's well maybe you
don't do that yes he was great you took
him in the 11th round last year you took
him in a 10th round last year you can
find these quarterbacks later on you can
go take carson wentz in the 8th round
you can go take drew brees in the ninth
round
Russell Wilson in the 10th round well
you want to go take Mitch to Biscay
played at a top-10 level last year you
can do that you can stream the position
Josh Allen Buffalo Bills look for legs
not these these aren't the ones you want
but Josh Allen had five top five
finishes last year he was great in the
fantasy playoff run in fact at times he
was better than mahomes you don't have
to take a quarterback early it's gonna
hurt the rest of your team don't hold
grudges like maybe I gave you bad advice
last year don't hold that against me
it's a new day yes it is and well we
talked about David Johnson and he may
have broken your heart last year I know
that
19:19 offense the wishbone or Wing T or
whatever it was whatever that coaching
staff did last year they're gone
Kliff Kingsbury is going to mend your
broken heart when it comes to look at
that it comes right back together to get
the smiling face of David Johnson we
have a coach from this century not only
David Johnson Carson Wentz two years ago
was the number two quarterback don't
hold that grudge he's okay he's healthy
is good to go Devonta Freeman missed
like all of last season time in
Coleman's gone he's the man now in
Atlanta so don't hold a grudge against
players who have hurt you in the past if
things have improved
do your research stay up on things
that's why I'm here
number four very important the waiver
wire is your friend let me tell you
something come here for something you
remember last year week 16 do you know
the name Eliza McGuire if you forgot
that's okay because maybe he beat you in
the championship or maybe you picked him
up
because he was so good against the Green
Bay Packers and now you're not drafting
him this year and that's okay because
you picked him off the waiver wire
Damian Williams who you are drafting
this year you picked him up and you
played him he was on the waiver wire
Jamal Williams in that same game Packers
Jets met nothing in real life meant
everything for fantasy Aaron Jones went
down you put Jamal Williams in there he
came through and won you a championship
if you're five and O and you get lazy
and you don't hit that waiver wire
you're going to lose if you draft three
running backs in the first four rounds
there you go I'm set there something's
going to happen someone's gonna get hurt
they're gonna get their coach mad at
them they're gonna miss a block
something's going to happen they're
gonna put the ball on the ground they're
gonna come off the field you can't plan
for those things you have to continue to
be vigilant on the waiver wire if you
want to win a fantasy championship we're
planning for the draft but it's not over
there hit that waiver wire and you will
win number five maybe the most important
rule don't drink more than the round
that you're in now I have taken time we
have a crack staff look at this
beautiful picture we put together
totally not from my wedding two years
ago same haircut and everything there is
the equation the round greater than
number of beers championship don't drink
eight beers by round two you might end
up with four quarterbacks and then you
can't trade any of them oh I'm so smart
I'll gather up all these quarterbacks Oh
nobody wants to trade with me now it's
fun the draft is one of the best days of
the year but draft and too much of on
draft during draft day is going to get
you in trouble don't ruin your entire
fantasy season because you overindulge
the more you know or something
those are my draft rules that's how it's
gonna help you get ready for your draft
and beyond but what we're gonna do here
now is answer more of your questions
from retro who's your deep sleeper
picked this year like Philip Lindsey or
Alvin Camaro or Devonta Freeman in
previous years
I like Myles Sanders of the Philadelphia
Eagles a player I think you'll get in
the sixth round can play the third round
value there's a really guy named I like
like Vance McDonald tight end for the
Pittsburgh Steelers a lot of targets
available go get him Tevin Coleman for
the Niners he's the man Kyle Shanahan
loves him no Shanta Hannigan's their big
d why do all the fantasy experts why'd
you put it in quotes spoil my sleepers
sometimes moving their ATP's up a few
rounds because we're doing our jobs and
we have to help more than just you then
that's okay we're here to help everybody
and that's exactly what we're gonna do
each week during the season but next
week next Thursday 3:00 Eastern new
Pacific we're right back here in Las
Vegas we'll be helping you out more to
get you ready for the drafts and don't
forget mock draft article that's out my
big board comes out next week and we'll
be with you every week 8:30 Pacific
11:30 Eastern on Sundays to get you
ready and I know I got some questions
but I'm gonna get to a lot more Q&A
coming up I'm gonna jump in the app and
we're gonna help you out I'm at camp and
I'll see you next week right here on
your fantasy fire drill
you